I have nothing against but here we show the
mine and I heard the wall of the notw
as much as we were going to stop at the following
[Music]
scores against 81.08 arenas at
all that this moment I am  happy
but that your prediction that if we get
there it won't be a blockade tale united
castans quentinois yet his motorcycle
when farting during my time at bern did
badly on the merits we it might khalifa
sall he added that martine aubry
we  already it wasn't good the
hillsides are being cautious this amount
is in progress
i'm talking gold in a ball of words i'm talking there
me i can't take it anymore
under montagny tanjombato gadio who does
so there it's there only names
threat species on an account our place
after a drive his car to madrid
and a couple in hassa kingdom russia
we love you suitable but on the
sources but after if that wasnt the
topic the week ap
the  attachment to tunis no madame monique
and champion of scoops
[Music]
I rode my wife he  Lena